hey guys it is the sixth of October
today my name is Jess and you're
watching against what news here's a mess
today after a hell of a long laid up
Ubisoft finally dropped the official
announcement trailer for the next entry
in the Far Cry series entitled Far Cry
primal unlike far cry 3 blood dragon Far
Cry primal is being described as a
full-fledged single-player experience
which will take place in 10,000 BC as
pacar a hunter and the last surviving
member of his hunting group ill traverse
an area called aura and try not to get
eaten by saber-tooth Tigers all goes by
rumor lips eerie soft have said you will
team up with the memorable cast of
characters to help you tend the
wilderness as with any good far cry game
expect hunting crafting and defending
off of to see predators the game is in
development activity soft emotional in
collaboration with Ubisoft Toronto
Ubisoft Shanghai studios and Ubisoft
Kiev studio far cry primal will be out
on febri 23 of next year for ps4 and
Xbox one while the PC Edition will be
out in March you can check out the full
cinematic trailer and behind-the-scenes
click in our story on site next up the
pc system requirements for star wars
battlefront have dropped and here's what
you'll need to run the thing minimum
system requirements for the game call
for a geforce gtx 660 with two gigabytes
of memory or a radeon HD 7850 graphics
card also with two Zika bytes of memory
the recommended settings are a little
easier you'll need an intel i5 6600
process of 16 gigabytes of ram a geforce
gtx 970 graphics card with 4 gigabytes
of memory or a radeon r9 290 with 4
gigabytes of memory both sets of
requirements also call for 40 gigabytes
of hard drive space and an intern
connection of at least 512 plymouth
seconds star wars battlefront ships to
ps4 xbox one and pc on november
seventeenth finally capcom has told fans
to stay tuned for resident evil 7 and
commented on their other titles producer
master chica kuwata told japanese gaming
magazine dengeki playstation that capcom
is not prepared to discuss resident evil
7 at a stage but did comment on the
suggestion that the game has lost its
horror touch kuwata explained since
there's been more spin-off titles i can
see how it can be perceived in such a
way and of course i believe that we
should produce titles that bring out the
horror i'm thinking about it and also
preparing for it kawada also mentioned
that they will consider more HD remakes
of classic rezzy games if there is
demand for them Capcom producer Hiroyuki
Kobayashi chimed in elsewhere in the
interview to note that there are
currently no plans when you devil may
cry or Dragon's Dogma games let me know
down in that comment section what you
think of Far Cry primal you can add the
games but we've got stories on sonic
lost world coming to pc and the most
anticipated holiday title that is
everything i have for you today as
always let me know what you cared about
and i look at you same time tomorrow